this is Startalk is there a theoretical
limit to the size of a son
I keep seeing graphics comparing our son
to larger and larger solar Giants just
how big can they get well would you get
to be a few hundred solar of sun
diameters you become a black hole really
yeah you become a star that has so much
gravity light doesn't escape but what I
call is would you describe it as over a
million wails yeah well that wouldn't be
an accurate well but over a million I
don't know a factor of I guess 10 to the
19th or something yeah like the whale
that's hanging from Neil's Museum
exactly those of you have been to New
York City to American Museum of Natural
History
so a Sun that was too big would just
become a black hole it would laughs yeah
well that's what it apparently it does
they do oh great yeah well that's up now
I know how to make a black hole
Thanks look out world
[Music]